dad you're a genius now that is how you
enter a room yeah especially if your dad
is Albert Einstein if your dad was
Ronald Reagan you say dad
you're an airport good
listen I've thought about Front Range
fashions offer and I'm not going to take
the buyout I am going to build the
company myself good idea
using my idea you're being smart Mandy
yeah slow and steady wins the race and
that's exactly how I want to do it
except instead of slow and steady I'm
gonna do it like super fast once you're
upstairs get that book tortoise in there
maybe this time she'll understand it uh
sweetie what exactly is your plan oh
we're actually still working out the
details no no we're not see um Kyle and
I have to face facts without the buyout
we can't afford to get the bitchin loft
downtown and put money into my company
well and you're not gonna like this
maybe you should wait on the bitchin
loft yeah exactly which is why we're
gonna move in with you I know this might
be too late to save it I'm not sure we
should have children